what does it take to be a great leader
in the room with hitler or
in the same time and space as hitler
to snuff him out to make the right
decisions
what what is so it sounds like you put
quite a bit of the blame on the man
chamberlain and give credit
to somebody like a churchill so what is
the difference where's that line you've
also
uh written a book about henry kissinger
who's an interesting sort of
person that's been through
throughout many difficult decisions in
the games of power so what does it take
to be a great leader in that moment that
particular moment sorry to keep talking
is fascinating to me because it feels
like it's man on man conversations that
define history well hitler was bluffing
uh he really wasn't ready for war in
1938 the german economy was clearly not
ready for war in 1938
and
and jaybalan made a fundamental
uh miscalculation along with his
advisors because it wasn't all
chamberlain he was in many ways
articulating
the establishment view
and i tried to show in a book called war
of the world how that establishment
worked it extended uh through the bbc
into the aristocracy to oxford there was
an establishment view chamberlain
personified it churchill was seen as a
warmonger
uh he was at his lowest point of
popularity in 1938 but what is what is
it that chamberlain gets wrong because
it's conceptual
chamberlain is persuaded that britain
has to play for time because britain is
not ready for war in 1938.
he fails to see that the time that he
gets that he buys at munich is also
available to hitler
everybody gets the time and hitler is
able to do much more with it because
hitler strikes the pact with uh with
stalin
that guarantees uh that germany can
fight a war on one front in 1939.
what does chamberlain do builds some
more aircraft
so the great mistake of the strategy of
appeasement was to play for time i mean
they knew all was coming but they were
playing for time not realizing that
hitler got the time too
and after he partitioned czechoslovakia
he was in a much stronger position not
least because of all the resources that
they were able to plunder uh
from czechoslovakia
so that was the conceptual mistake
churchill
played
an heroic role in pointing out
this mistake and predicting accurately
that it would lead to war on worse terms
what does it take
it takes a
distinct courage
to be unpopular and churchill was deeply
unpopular at that point people would
listen to him in the house of commons in
silence on one occasion uh
lady astor shouted rubbish
so he went through a period of being
hated on
the other thing that made churchill a
formidable leader was that he always
applied history to the problem
and that's why he gets it right he he
sees the historical problem much more
clearly than than chamberlain so i think
if you go back to 1938
there's no realistic counterfactual in
which churchill's in government in 1938
you have to france collapse for
churchill to come into government
but you can certainly imagine
a
tory elite
that's thinking more clearly
about the likely dynamics
they haven't seen this
i guess problem of conjecture to take a
phrase from kissinger
which is that whatever they're doing
in postponing
the war has the potential
to create a worse starting point for the
war
it would have been risky in 1938 but it
was a way better situation than they
ended up with in 1939 a year later
you asked about kissinger and i've
learnt a lot from reading kissinger and
talking to kissinger since i embarked on
writing his biography
great many years ago
i think one of the most important things
i've learned
uh
is that
you can apply history to contemporary
problems it may be the most important
tool that we have in
that kind of decision making
you have to do it quite
ruthlessly and rigorously
and in the moment of crisis
you have to take risk
so
kissinger often says in his early work
the temptation of the bureaucrat is to
wait for more data
but ultimately the decision
making that we do under uncertainty
can't be based on data
the problem of conjecture is that you
could take an action now and incur some
cost
and avert disaster
but you'll get no thanks for it because
nobody is grateful for an averted
disaster
and nobody goes around saying wasn't it
wonderful how we didn't have another 911
on the other hand you can do nothing
incur no upfront costs and hope for the
best
and you might get lucky the disaster
might not happen
that's in a democratic system the much
easier
path to take
and i think
the the essence of leadership is to be
ready
to take that upfront cost avert the
disaster and accept that you won't get
gratitude
you